like this
and your wife
good morning
I don't like water
how are you
bye
[Music]
and
I don't either
god probox good
I'm
[Music]
why these trails
to their crops
if it's not so much if their percussion
even  faith
there is a constitution
in my name and as
ah
now pumas
with then power
grimms respect
and already yesterday
house
bike sometimes sex
well
the ine
frets like
the report
reprimand
as
ricardo montesanti bertolo
there is a
firewall sometimes
way
[Music]
and
efe
wow
since it wasn't
[Music]
in this known as insurance because yes
one night omission
I don't
have a fair trade
[Music]
winston reid
com
but at that point
to
pachuca meaning style
[Music]